le plus dur est de se laisser aimer
comme l'on est c'est ça qui vous
raisonne OK et
pourquoi le public vous aime tel que
vous êtes ouais mes amis aussi voilà
autrement ils s'en vont voilà les plus
proches les plus proches et c'est qui
c'est qui les plus proche on va dire ma
sœur ouais et qui d'autre encore
un degré moins proche ma mère et mon
père et un de qui est encore plus proche
plus proche ouais moi vous allez dire
c'est
moi-même moi-même plus on va avancer
dans la semaine et plus on va prendre
conscience de tout ce qui est là dans
not trip et de qui suis-je parce qu'en
fait on repart la question de départ
mais ouis c'est ça qui
suis-je qui suis-je appelé à aimer ou
est-ce que c'est pas moi-même bah oui
c'est ça en fait pour l'instant oui
ouis c'est ça en fait il faut se
recentrer